lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
darte una idea intuitiva de cómo
funciona realmente un mercado de divisas
y es que lo que pasa es que es muy poco
intuitivo para mucha gente porque vamos
a hablar de divisas que se vuelven más
caras o baratas y más baratas o el
precio de una divisa que se vuelve más
cara o barata en términos de otra y lo
que quiero hacer es darte una idea muy
intuitiva de esto así que digamos ya ya
que es un tema muy popular en estos días
tomemos las siguientes dos divisas el
renminbi de china y el dólar de eeuu y
la unidad de intercambio y con china es
un poco confuso porque a veces usan
renminbi y otras veces de liu el yuan el
yuan es la unidad de cambio del renminbi
así que digamos que justo ahora si yo
entrara digamos a una página web y este
no es el tipo de cambio real en este
momento pero supongamos que justo ahora
el tipo de cambio es de es de 10 x
por cada dólar de eeuu ok entonces
visión eso es igual a un dólar y cada
vez que digan dólar en este vídeo me
refiero al dólar de eeuu ok
creo que esto tiene sentido para mucha
gente si tengo un dólar y quiero
convertir lo ayudan obtengo 10 de estos
si tengo 10 giovanni quiero convertirlos
a dólares alguien me dará un dólar por
ellos ahora imaginemos una situación y
en los siguientes vídeos construiré
desbalances en intercambios donde de
hecho eso suceda
pero vamos a suponer que vivimos en una
realidad donde hay mí
hay mil digamos que hay que alguien
tiene million así que digamos que esta
persona aquí tiene 1000 joan ok aquí
tiene sus
este tiene tiene mil one
y no solo tiene esos millones sino que
además quiere convertirlos a dólares
y quiere convertirlos y quiere
convertirlos a dólares
ahora digamos que de este otro lado ok
si miráramos superficialmente estos 1000
joan y miramos la tasa de cambio bien
diríamos esos million los dividimos
sabiendo que 10 iván valen un dólar
entonces tendríamos 100 dólares pero
bueno este mercado involucra muchos
otros aspectos esto nos ayudará a
simplificar o al menos entender cómo
funcionan estas tasas de intercambio
digamos que esta persona de aquí no sé
esta persona con bigote y digamos que
esta persona de aquí vamos a ponerle un
sombrero también digamos que tiene el 50
dólares no no perdón
de 50 dólares no no me agrada
digamos que tienen 100 dólares ok
ok entonces tiene 100 dólares
y necesita
necesita convertirlos
a one quizá quiere comprar algunos
productos chinos quién sabe quizás es el
dueño de una fábrica china que vendió
sus productos en eeuu por 100 dólares y
ahora necesita convertirlos de regreso a
yuan para pagarle a sus empleados una
hipoteca o quién sabe digamos que hay
otra persona digamos que hay otro
personaje por aquí digamos que este es
una chica y que también tiene 100
dólares que necesita convertir ayudan
aunque también tiene tiene 100 100
dólares
necesita necesita convertir convertir
y muy bien así que aquí que sucede aquí
cuál es la demanda total para convertir
joana dólares y de dólares ayudan bueno
si miras la totalidad del mercado tienes
200 dólares que quieren ser convertidos
hay un déjenme escribir eso aquí tenemos
esta situación donde 200 dólares 200
dólares
necesitan ser convertidos convertidos
joan
y luego del otro lado de esta
transacción tenemos 1000 joan que
necesitan convertirse a dólares ok
así que tenemos milián de ponerlo aquí
tenemos mil one
minion que necesitan ser convertidos
convertidos
a dólares y por simplicidad asumamos que
estos son los únicos actores ellos
representan a todo el mercado aunque
como sabemos en los mercados de divisas
especialmente existen muchísimos miles o
millones de actores participando
activamente así que qué va a suceder
toda esta gente podría entrar en
internet y buscar la tasa de cambio
actual
o el último más reciente y decide si
sabes que yo aquí con estos 100 dólares
debería ser imposible convertirlos en
million pero ella también dice debería
poder cambiar estos 100 dólares a mil
yuan así que colectivamente ellos
piensan que 200 dólares se pueden
convertir en 2000 one
así que pondré eso entre signos de
interrogación le será posible convertir
esto en 2000 one
podrán convertirlo en 2000 jon y esta
persona que dice el bueno al tipo de
cambio actual quizás pueden obtener mis
million quizás pueda obtener 100 dólares
por esos million pero todos buscan
maximizar la cantidad de la otra moneda
que obtiene por obvias razones quieren
maximizar la cantidad de dinero ahora
estas dos personas podrían convertir su
dinero a dos mil one recuerda lo que
dije es que este es un mercado entero es
una muy grande simplificación pero hay
un desbalance aquí hay más dólares que
johann ahora ellos no podrán convertir a
2000 jon porque sólo hay mil de estos en
ser cambiados sólo hay mil yuan que van
a ser intercambiados así que puedes
imaginar que este señor de aquí quizá él
quiere hacerlo lentamente solo para ver
de alguna forma cómo está el mercado y
digamos que al inicio pone 10 yuan en el
mercado esencialmente no oferta lo
puedes hacer de cualquier manera tú
podrías decir que quizás una de estas
personas pone un dólar en oferta y este
señor está ofertando por ese dólar en
términos de johann o este señor está
ofertando johann en fin estas personas
van a ofertar en términos de 2
de cualquier manera y por eso es a veces
un poco confuso lo de las divisas porque
estás comprando moneda de otros países
pero dado que la divisa de este señor
tiene más demanda ok
tiene más demanda para simplificar lo
haré el tipo de persona que es de cierta
manera capaz de crear una situación
similar a una subasta lo cual es
realmente lo que los mercados tratan de
hacer de manera que puedas igualar
oferta y demanda y entonces él podría
decir inicialmente
sabes que quiero convertir el tiene 100
johann y quiere convertirlos así que
dice estoy dispuesto a vender 100 one
por 10 dólares así que digamos que al
inicio va a vender vende 100
o debería decir más bien ofertar oferta
vender 10 perdón 100 yohan por 10
dólares por 10 dólares y ella piensa que
ese es un precio de oferta justo aquí y
este tipo de aquí el de arriba también
también piensa lo mismo entonces qué va
a pasar bueno una de estas personas
simplemente balanzas se vivirá o sabes
que creo que este es un muy buen precio
y digamos que es bueno ambos quieren
tomar la oferta pero la mujer le da un
clic en su mouse más rápido que el otro
y entonces como sea que estén realizando
la transacción el punto es que vamos a
suponer que esta persona que le vamos a
llamar la persona ve porque esta es la
persona ve digamos que esta es la y este
de acá es el c entonces digamos que la
persona ve acepta por lo que dos cosas
acaban de suceder fíjense la persona ve
acepta
así que acaban de suceder dos cosas una
es la persona se dice bueno eso fue
bastante rápido alguien realmente
deseaba tomar los 10 iván por dólar
ok eso por un lado y entonces el otro
tipo de icio necesito convertir mi
dinero ayudan pero no pude alguien más
me gano así que este señor de aquí dice
x a la gente está dispuesta a darme más
dólares por johann ok así que imaginemos
que este señor de aquí el señor de
naranja él ofrece vender ahora ofrece
ofrece vender
digamos que ahora quiere vender 90 joan
91 por 10 dólares
notemos que el precio del joan ahora ha
aumentado o el precio del dólar ha
disminuido lo puedes ver de ambas formas
cualquiera de los dos son enunciados
simétricos significan exactamente lo
mismo entonces de pronto esta persona
tiene muchos dólares que necesita
convertir ayuda así que acepta
rápidamente así que la persona acepta en
esta vez está haciendo una gran
simplificación pero te da una idea
general para de cómo se maneja esto
entonces aquí la persona acepta y
tenemos una nueva tasa de cambio de
pronto tenemos una tasa de cambio de qué
es esto de 9 one
9 bueno así que tenemos una nueva tasa
de cambio es 99 jones por dólar
ahora qué es lo que pasa creo que puedes
ver la dinámica de lo que va a suceder
hay más dólares que necesitan ser
convertidos a johann que johann que
necesitan ser convertidos a dólares así
que este señor conforme ve que hay mucha
demanda para obtener sus million va a
seguir ofreciendo cada vez menos iván
por dólar o estas personas comenzarán a
aceptar cada vez menos yuan por cada uno
de sus dólares ok
así que mientras esto sucede el precio
del yuan irá para arriba note que el
precio del yuan si se va para arriba
porque era 10 por dólar y ahora es de 9
iván por dólar o puedes decir que el
precio del dólar baja y esto continuará
sucediendo hasta que todos ellos se
pueden deshacer de sus de sus divisas no
hay fórmula matemática que diga cuál es
el precio de venta de hecho depende de
cuánto des en cada una de estas personas
realizar esa transacción y realmente en
qué tan buenos sean en ganarle uno al
otro pero el resultado general y eso es
lo que quiero que entiendas en este
vídeo el resultado general es que ya que
no hay una ley en el mecanismo de la
tasa de cambio en un mercado de divisas
que diga
esta tiene que ser la tasa de cambio
bueno exploraremos cómo se puede fijar
esto en el futuro pero no hay nada que
diga que tiene que ser siempre el caso
si hay más demanda de jong que dólares
como vimos en este ejemplo el precio del
dólar irá para abajo
el dólar mira para abajo para esto
aquí el precio del dólar
va para abajo y luego que es exactamente
lo mismo en significa exactamente lo
mismo que el precio del yuan del yuan
que sube ok subirá realmente quiero que
internalice sé esto irá para arriba en
términos de dólares verdad el precio de
los dólares en términos de johann irá
para abajo y esta es la cruz del
intercambio de divisas y puedes al menos
internalizar estas ideas y entender que
realmente hay un mercado aquí ya basado
en la oferta y la demanda de lyon la
demanda de lyon está excediendo su
oferta por lo que el precio irá para
arriba y
o lo puedes ver de la otra manera que la
demanda de dólares está por debajo de la
oferta por lo que su precio irá para
abajo de cualquier forma te dejaré
pensando sobre esto por un momento en el
siguiente vídeo vamos a aplicar este
concepto para ver cómo este tipo de
cambio flotante
puede ayudar a igualar o debería igualar
desequilibrios comerciales